>> Kagure, why is Sickle cell anemia en,
endemic to regions like Kenya and, and Africa?
>> So, it's higher in the region
because it provides resistance, some resistance to malaria.
>> I see. So malaria is a common sickness?
>> Yes, definitely.
>> Definitely.
>> I've had malaria, everyone else in my family has had malaria too.
>> Really? What's it like to have malaria?
>> you,
malaria is, like the flu.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I've never had the flu, but from what people describe the flu as.
>> You get dizzy, you get nauseous, you're, you get achy
joints. when I had malaria, I remember being very dizzy, dizzy
enough that the floor seemed very far away and like it
was teetering. And you're just kind of out. You get a fever.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The usual.
>> And how does the, and I mean, how does
malaria spread?
>> Malaria is spread through mosquitoes.
>> Through mosquitoes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so, we, the best way to combat that
then is just like, bug spray or bug nets or something?
>> So, the best way would be, you don't want
to have pools of water, stagnant water, outside your home.
>> Mm-hm.
>> because they're attracted to that. So if
you had a drum of water just sitting
outside your window. You going to get a bunch
of mosquitoes just hanging out waiting for nighttime, or
whenever. you also want to have a mesh, screens on your windows
and doors, so that when you do need to open your windows, bugs can't get in.
And then another way, if you can't do all of that, is you need
to have mosquito nets over your beds. At night because that's the time when.
>> Mm-hm.
>> They're likely to strike when you're just kind of lying there and still.
>> Wow so you're
pretty sure most people are sure that when they get malaria
is because you know mosquito bit them at some point, probably.
>> Yes.
>> And so it's pretty common. You've had
it, you said everyone in your family's had it?
>> Right. Have you, do people get it multiple times?
>> Yes.
>> Say, i, is there treatment for it?
>> There is treatment for malaria. You go to the
hospital or clinic or your doctor and you get medication.
I'm not sure what it was exactly. I think
you take it for granted because it's so common.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You just go in and they prescribe you something. And you get better.
>> How long does it take to get better?
>> I know people who go back to work or to school after three
days. And then I know people who'll stay home sick for a few weeks. It
just depends on the person and how early you caught it as well. I
tend to catch mine early because my stomach hurts and then, for me that's the
main symptom and then I kind of ignore that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Whereas with others if they're just feeling a little under the
weather, they'll think to themselves I'm just a little tired, I'll go home.
>> So you mention that the reason sickle cell
anemia is higher in Kenya is because it provides some
resistance to malaria, but if you have one allele
for, the sickle cell how exactly does it provide resistance?
>> So I think
what it is when you have sickle cell anemia
is that your red blood cells are crescent shaped.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And this makes it makes some resistant to infection from the parasite.
>> I see so it's sort of trade off then. I mean
sickle cell anemia doesn't sound like a good thing but neither's malaria
[LAUGH].
And.
>> True.
>> So if it provides some advantage then
that's probably why it's more prevalent in the region.
>> Yeah, I think that's true. But then, isn't there something
about sickle cell anemia where you don't live past a certain, where
more people with sickle cell anemia will not live past a
certain age. And so in that way with malaria you can get
treatment and live to be 80 and then with sickle
cell anemia, it, you're more likely to have a shorter lifespan.
>> That's a really good point. So the
while if you have sickle cell anemia, you
have to have two copies of the allele to have sickle cell. If you're just a
carrier, you have one copy, which provides resistance
against malaria too, but you don't have any
of the symptoms of anemia. But you raise
a really interesting point though, that actually our
treatment of malaria means that you don't, there's
no natural selection happening as much. Or there's
not as much happening because we don't, you
don't need the sickle cell to protect you from
malaria as much because now we have drugs
right. So you're not going to die from malaria
as frequently when we have drugs. And now
that means that okay, the sickle cell allele actually
isn't being naturally selected for anymore. So although
we have drugs to treat malaria and help
you get better, sickle cell anemia, the alleles
still exist but actually it's not being selected for
anymore. But it's so prevalent in the region,
but as you move away from regions that
are stricken with malaria, you don't see the
sickle cell allele. At all,really. if you could give
advice to somebody who either is going to a region
with malaria, or is, you know, grown up in a region
and has just gotten malaria for the first time, do
you have any advice what to do when you get malaria?
>> Well, first of all, for someone going
to an area that has malaria, I would say
[LAUGH]
you need to go get yeah, anti-malaria tells, you want to
go. You want to be prepared because you probably don't have
resistance to the parasite yet. And so it's important
to go to a travel clinic or wherever, and get.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Something anti-malaria pills, for someone whose having it
for the first time. See a doctor, don't take chances,
don't let stay too long because it can kill you.
and that's pretty much it. Don't freak out, there's treatment.